hi this is Mark Cuban I'm about to go
undercover on the Internet this is
actually me Wikipedia
Mark Cuban hates meetings he has said
the only way you're gonna get me for a
meeting is if you're writing me a check
yes
I hate meetings nobody likes meetings
except the people who bring the donuts
and the people who love to talk about
their kids because when you sit in a
meeting you waste half the meeting so
how was your weekend how's your day why
don't they get the right kind of
doughnuts I'm tired of doughnuts we
should get cupcakes all this nonsense
that has nothing to do with getting the
job done I have so many different
investments so many businesses I'm
involved with I want to do everything
via email because that allows me to go
back and look something up so if you
told me bla bla bla your kids and I said
oh that's sweet and then we talked about
business I can go back and search it
five years ten years twenty years I got
emails that are twenty-five years old
now since Gmail you know takes gigabytes
and gigabytes of storage I can just do
search so I don't even have to organize
them but I make an exception if you're
gonna write me a check and it's a big
one I'll be there Quorra how did Mark
Cuban turn the Mavs around from a
business perspective well I'm gonna be
brutally honest I really didn't care
about the business of the Dallas
Mavericks
when I bought them I really cared about
winning championships and winning games
and so I spent a whole lot more time on
the basketball side of things and the
Mavs lost money almost every year until
the past three years when I got to the
NBA when I bought the Dallas Mavericks
everybody thought we sold basketball
very few people go to basketball games
to watch basketball think about the last
sporting event you went to do you
remember a jump shot do you remember a
dunk do you even remember the score
maybe you remember who we played but you
remember who you were with it's an
experience you remember how you felt
when that balls in the air and it's a
tie game if it goes through the hoop you
win and if it doesn't you lose everybody
collectively twenty thousand people are
holding their breath and when it goes
through the hoop you're high-fiving and
a hugging and squeezing so tight people
you've never seen before in your life
you're walking out of the arena
screaming and yelling and if you loose
you do the exact opposite Apple one of
the biggest companies in the world they
could have their best quarter their best
year ever no one's throwing a parade in
Cupertino the Dallas Mavericks win a
championship Dallas is on fire
everybody's having an amazing time the
whole city feels the energy you feel
that energy when you walk into the arena
that's what I convinced the NBA that we
sell and that literally changed all
sports was sold posted IMDB after he
sold his first company he tried acting
without much success and even auditioned
for a role in the film twister in 1996
but lost out to Philip Seymour Hoffman
yes that's true after I sold my first
company then I started trading
technology stocks I did so well I turned
that into a hedge fund and almost
immediately sold that moved out to LA to
live on the beach and just be retired
and I took acting classes why cuz I
wanted to meet people that I did I got
to take classes of all kinds of bit
while this back in the day the cast of
In Living Color all these different
shows and so I started auditioning those
audition for commercials you know I had
to put the Taco Bell hat on and just act
stupid did some Ford commercials so I
auditioned for a movie twister and got a
callback got another callback I'm
thinking yeah and then didn't get a
callback
I forget the role but the name of the
role but dusty yeah dusty and so I'm
thinking I'm dusty well then I watched
the movie Philip Seymour Hoffman is
dusty Academy Award actor I would I
would I was right for the role he was
miscast Twitter what do you give a
billionaire on Valentine's Day coupons
definitely not chocolates you know what
a nice hello goes a long way a little
kindness I think that's what I want for
Valentine's Day my most memorable
Valentine's Day would not be
family-friendly right about now so we'll
pass on that one
how did Mark Cuban save his wealth from
the dot-com crash he sold broadcast calm
for 5.7 billion in Yahoo stock how did
he get out before it all went down well
I'm gonna tell you
before we started broadcast comm as
audio net in the mid 90s I had sold
couple companies and traded stocks a lot
I made a lot of money trading technology
stocks when we took broadcast comm
public in 1998 our first-day IPO price
the increase was the largest increase
for an IPO in the history of the stock
market at the time and then Yahoo bought
us for 5.7 billion dollars and stuff
some people thought the stock market was
going to go up forever I had more than a
billion dollars to my name they said oh
you should just keep your stock and
don't do anything with it because it's
gonna keep on going up forever I was
worth more than a billion dollars how
much money do you need there's no reason
to be greedy I didn't need more I just
needed to keep what I had
I watched my broker and I did something
called a caller and I had to wait six
months and that was a nerve-racking six
months but I sold what's called calls on
Yahoo which gave somebody else to write
to buy it at a higher price and I used
that money to buy something called puts
which meant if the stock dropped below a
certain point I was able to sell that
stock at the value of the put when the
internet stock market bubble burst that
saved me you know was unfortunate a lot
of people lost a lot of money and
impacted the economy I was able to
protect myself but it was really
building of the fact that I wasn't greed
looking back there's been articles
written about that trade that's been
called one of the top 10 stock trades of
all time if you're buying and trading
stocks always remember this when you
think you've made the best stock by ever
you are so smart and everybody knows
this stock is going up forever ask
yourself why somebody sold it to you I'm
not saying sell your stocks I'm not
saying the markets going to go down I
don't know and neither do you so be
careful now I'm getting all preachy
Instagram honest question I'll preface
it by saying I truly think you're the
best owner in team sports thanks David
what was the process you went through
when you overruled your management team
and passed on giannis if you don't know
Yanis inst comfo the Greek freak
probably gonna win the MVP for the
Milwaukee Bucks and in 2013 our general
manager Donnie Nelson said we have to
get this kid if you're a basketball fan
you know the Greek who the Greek freak
freak is you know how amazing is he
back then there were two VHS tapes of
him playing in this horrible little
league that probably wasn't as good as
the league I played in at the gym we
just had these tapes but our guys had
gone to see him they said this is the
guy he's gonna be really good
and I'm like who else was watching this
kid if he's going to be a superstar you
would think somebody would draft him the
double bad news was not only do we not
get the Greek freak and missed out on
him but we also didn't get the free
agents we wanted either so we got shut
out thanks for asking that question
why does Mark Cuban do his own laundry
now first of all I don't always do my
own laundry
when I travel I do my own laundry I just
do
but my wife kills me because I don't use
laundry detergent like for workout gear
I'll just throw it into the washing
machine there's no good reason other
than laziness and then I'll just throw
it into the dryer but you know sets a
good example for my kids if dad's doing
his own laundry I don't have a good
reason beyond that which companies that
have appeared on shark tank does Mark
Cuban regret not investing it none none
when we come to shoot they'll just bring
in deal after deal after deal and when
they walk in we know nothing about them
they'll just start pitching us and we
have to decide what we're going to do
right there and then a shark tank deal
on television might be 10 14 minutes
they can go 30 45 90 minutes two hours
imagine those one after another for
weeks at a time once they leave they are
gone lost forgotten I don't pay
attention to any deals that I didn't get
as Kevin would say they're dead to me em
Cuban we all know you sold garbage bags
door-to-door I'm doing that right now
why I have no idea but what were the
following six job I sold garbage bags
door-to-door when I was 12 years old
because my dad told me the only way I
could get new basketball shoes was if I
had a job and one of his buddies said I
have all these garbage bags to sell why
don't you sell him so I sold him
door-to-door got my kicks my next six
jobs oh my god I was a box boy I got a
job working on a delicatessen I was
chopping chip chopped ham if you're from
Pittsburgh
you know what chip chopped ham is what's
the paying attention and this finger
went right into the blade that was
spinning around and chopped off the end
of my finger went flying on a bully
everywhere that job ended like that
after that I had a bunch of odd jobs
laying carpet just random random jobs
I'm CUBAN renting a book on maths
history you would play wiffle ball in
the first mansion you bought after the
broadcast calm sail accurate absolutely
one of my former partners came to me and
said there's this enormous house that
some guys spent twenty five million
dollars to build and I could get it for
half the cost that he cut to custom to
build twelve million dollars I said I'll
buy it sight unseen the place is
enormous 24,000 square feet aren't even
still to this day don't know how many
bedrooms or bathrooms a year or two
would go by and I wouldn't go upstairs
and you know there were rooms I had
still haven't been in in years in the
ballroom there was a fireplace a window
there's a pillar and there's a bar home
plate first base second base third base
I had a wiffle ball bat and a wiffle
ball because every guy who lives on
their own does my buddies would come
over then it was big enough you can
curve the ball and hit and run and hit
homeruns and until I got married
effectively I had no furniture and we
played wiffle ball in my ball room I
still had the house and I still had the
wiffle ball bat and literally just the
other day the dog ate the wiffle ball if
your tax rate was dropped to say zero
would you take that money not paid in
taxes and give it to the workers in your
companies in my opinion the idea that
corporation would is unfounded I'll tell
you exactly what I would do if you
remember what I said about broadcast
comm when we sold the company out of
three hundred and thirty employees three
hundred own shares of stock and became
millionaires in my companies that I
start everybody has stock if taxes went
to zero and I don't think that's a good
idea but if taxes did go to zero I would
invest in the company to make it as big
and profitable so stinking profitable
that because the employees are owners
whenever I got paid they would get paid
too when you get paid by the hour sure
the more you make the better things are
but if you own stock in a company then
the better that company does the better
you do and the only way to get out of
that mode of getting paid by the hour
getting paid a salary is if the company
grows as big as it possibly can neither
generates a lot of cash so that you get
paid
where the company gets sold and to me
that's how you start to fight income
inequality during college he had various
business ventures including a bar disco
lessons and a chain letter yes I did I
went to Indiana University and I had to
pay for my own school well I had to
figure out every which way in order to
do it the chain letter was my junior
year you buy the chain letter from
somebody and then the letter is a list
of ten names you give $50 to the person
you bought the letter from and you send
$50 to the person at the top of the list
scratch their name off put your name at
the bottom then find at least ten people
to sell it to so that one by one your
name works its way to the top of the
list while I did that and got my name to
the top of the list and I also sold it
so that none of the people I sold it to
lost any money because I would have felt
horrible I remember getting up every
morning so excited because there'd be
like envelopes with 50 bucks here 50
bucks there it was it was amazing it was
great it was illegal but that was my
chain letter my junior year and that's
how I paid for my junior year of college
now in term of disco lessons I needed a
job I like to dance I always like to
dance I was okay at it
I was out dancing with some friends at a
club somebody saw me and they're like we
need you to give disco lessons at our
sorority house cool how much you gonna
pay me they're like $25 an hour
oh my yes I got to go to a sorority
house who then referred me to another
sorority house who done referred me to
another sorority house it was the
happiest time of my life I can't show
them all the place I would dance we
would throw parties there I'd act as a
party promoter but that bar was going
out of business I took another student
alone fifteen hundred I think it was I
went to my friend and he had some money
Evan we said okay we want to take over
the bar and I don't really have much
cash to give you but I want to turn it
from a disco into more of a rock
oriented dance and hang out and party
bar and they were like cool and so we
wrote up a little contract and I mean I
was so stupid I'd even use a lawyer I
was able to take over the bar and
effectively buy it we took all the disco
stuff out put in the best sound system
and stereo system that we could find if
we didn't have a lot of people come
those first couple days we were out of
business immediately I was using my
student loan money and I still had to
pay for college and it would have been a
big problem we opened up and there were
lines to get
how did I open it being under 21 they
didn't ask him I didn't tell you agree
with Mark Cuban that liberal arts
graduates will become more valuable in
the future twelve years ago there was no
iPhone 25 years ago the internet was
just happening 30 years ago we were just
seeing PCs and we'd come so far just
with that artificial intelligence and
the advances it introduced is just gonna
dwarf iPhones you know local area
networks the internet it's just gonna
blow them away we're gonna start using
AI for a lot of different applications
in jobs if you're gonna build an AI a
neural network that is about Shakespeare
if that's about customer service in
telecommunications
that's about any particular topic you
need someone with expertise not only in
their topics but people who are able to
be able to put together objective
network so that they're able to find and
eliminate biases wherever they find them
humanities and technology in the world
of artificial intelligence have to come
together otherwise we're gonna see all
kinds of problems data is going to drive
everything that we do we're really gonna
live in a completely different world and
even though technology might not have
been the same 50 100 500 years ago
typically we tend to go through the same
types of problems and having people with
a perspective that's different than a
technologist will be incredibly valuable
that's it for today I've answered your
questions
this was actually me